the southwestern corner of Azerbaijan is
being transformed known by Armenians as
nagorno-karabakh they occupied this
territory for 30 years but war in 2020
saw the azares win back control of
almost all of it we belong to this land
we came back and we found ruins
destruction demolished everything
demolished our cemeteries completely
destroyed
the ethnic Armenians that were here have
gone the cathedral hit by shelling will
be rebuilt we're told as Eerie families
will move here when reconstruction is
finished
the azeri government says it's investing
1.6 billion dollars in the territories
taken back from Armenian control that
includes here in shusha where we're
overlooking the only part of karabakh
that remains under the control of ethnic
Armenians the town of kankandi or as the
Armenians call it stepanakert
at least 70 000 ethnic Armenians live
down there effectively surrounded and
Azerbaijan has now installed aboard a
checkpoint on the only road linkings to
panicert to Armenia it's supposed to
remain open under the terms of a Russian
brokered peace deal that ended the 2020
War it had already been partly blocked
for three months by self-styled
environmental activists we have seen
many times on many occasions the video
footage the facts where the Russian
peacekeepers would
assist would help Armenian illegal
military troops to uh to use this road
bring some new ammunitions weapons and
as a result of this of course it posed
very serious security
concerns azerbaijanic government and
azerbaijanic government decided to stop
this
Armenia says the allegations are
far-fetched insta panicert the
administration says it's been getting by
on what little supplies are allowed
through people have been living on
minimal goods and food transported with
the help of Russian peacekeepers in the
Red Cross people are living with
permanent cuts of electricity and gas we
have a problem with access to medical
treatment and every day this
humanitarian crisis is deepening the
checkpoint is an azerbaijani move that
further worsens the situation
Armenia relies on Russia as a security
guarantor it believes that Kremlin
hasn't been fulfilling its role several
servicemen from both sides have been
killed in clashes in recent months and
tensions are high again Bernard Smith Al
Jazeera shusha Azerbaijan